AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME, SPAT
CHAT.
SPAT CHAT.
THE GREAT PART ABOUT PLAYING A
GAME LIKE HALO 5: GUARDIANS
ONLINE IS YOU GET TO COMPETE
AGAINST REAL PEOPLE.
♪ ♪
(GUNFIRE)
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
YEAH.
(FUNCHES WHOOPS)
THAT-THAT WAS ME DOING ALL THAT
[BLEEP].
UH...
UNFORTUNATELY, SOMETIMES YOUR
OPPONENT TRIES TO THROW YOUR
GAME OFF BY GIVING YOU BAD
ADVICE OR QUESTIONING YOUR
MOTHER'S MORAL CHARACTER.
SO, COMEDIANS, STRAP ON YOUR
HALO HEADSETS AND SAY SOME
THINGS YOU WOULDN'T WANT TO HEAR
WHILE PLAYING "HALO 5:
GUARDIANS" ONLINE.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK.
AND BEGIN.
(BELL DINGS)
FUNCHES.
>> (WHOOPS) UH, WHILE WE'RE DONE
PLAYIN', I ACTUALLY JUST WANTED
TO LET YOU KNOW, THIS IS HILLARY
CLINTON AND I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW WHO YOU WERE GONNA VOTE
FOR.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
STEVE.
>> I FARTED SO BAD YOUR EARS
WILL SMELL IT IN THREE, TWO...
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
BRIAN POSEHN.
>> HEY, IT'S ME, THE GUY THAT
JUST BEAT YOU.
I WAS BORN IN 2003.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
BRIAN POSEHN AGAIN.
>> SIR, THIS IS THE POLICE.
THE ASS-KICKING IS COMING FROM
INSIDE THE HOUSE.
>> HARDWICK: UH, POINTS.
(BELL DINGS)
STEVE.
>> IT'S YOUR FATHER.
YOUR MOTHER AND I ARE GETTING A
DIVORCE.
ALSO, NO SPAWN CAMPING.
(BUZZER SOUNDS)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.